ladies I've made my decision
[Music]
soju your time here is short but you'll
always be part of our family now sashay
away
thank you
[Music]
the shot of soju the time on the show is
done what do you hope The fans walk away
thinking about soju mm-hmm I want so I
want people to think of me as like a
genuine Queen I'm not really like the
you know tongue popping because I can't
do it and like I'm not like oh yeah it's
go back you know what I mean I'm not
explosive like that but at the same time
I keep it genuine you know what I mean
and I love the art and I'm very
passionate about it and you know I have
a lot to give and I hope you know the
fans can see that too if you had to boil
down your drag race experience and to
just a few words what would those words
be Oh exciting emotional dramatic and
you know unexpected yeah yeah surprising
so it was like everything you thought it
would be and more yeah like you can
never be fully ready for it you know
like you think you me as a review person
like I would think I thought that I knew
exactly what was gonna happen but it's
nothing like it and it's exciting
because it's something new and I thought
I was gonna be so like like ready for it
but there's no really getting ready for
you just have to live in the moment and
be excited about it if you want to pour
soju she'll be cranking out drag race
content all season long over on her
YouTube channel that was soldier review
we do a live review after the episode
and I've been getting a lot of heat from
like other drag queens you know for
doing the reviews because you know I
invite all my local sisters in Chicago
to you know speak freely about you know
what they think of the episode and stuff
so there's some love there and then
there's some you know shade there and
I've been you know I love it though like
you know whatever if they hate it
because you know put their own beauty so
right now you can judge me
[Music]